مساء الخير
في عام 1991 دخلت الجامعه
باصرار من والدي
رفاقي ذهبوا باتجاه العمل بعد البكالوريا
وانا امامي عده سنوات
للدراسه وساخذ مصروفي من والدي في حين انه
رفاقي اصبحوا مستقلين في الحياه اصبحوا
بالنسبه لرجال وانا لا ازال طالب
الحقيقه
ان والدي كان مصر اني نحقق حلمي بان اصبح
دكتور
حتى انه هو من ملا استماره المفاضل
الجامعي ووضع فيها اختصاص ريفيكاف رياضيات
فيزياء كيمياء الزمان
لما لم يكن لدي اي خيار الا ان امشي بهذا
الخط وحقق الحلم اللي وجهني عليه والدي
طبعا يعني
النزاع داخل الصراع الداخلي من ما بين اني
اصبح رجل مستقل ساعد والدي وبين اني اخذ
مصروفي من والدي عده سنوات امريكان يسبب
لي كتير من الالم لكن هذا الالم هو اللي
ولد عندي اني رد الجميل واتفوق في الدراسه
وفعلا
فوقت كنت من المتفوقين وحصلت على المرتبه
الاولى المرتبه الاولى اللي خلتني سمحتلي
باني احصل على منحه من حكومه بلدي سوريا
حتى ادرس الدكتوراه في فرنسا طبعا حصلت
على ست سنوات درست فيها سنه لغه
سنه دبلوم دراسات معمقه واربع سنين
دكتوراه عم اسكر هذه الامور حقيقه تشير
الى عده نقاط اهمها
انه في طور الشباب الانسان بحس حاله بلغ
وبيعرف يقرر مساره خطه
لكن في الحقيقه ما في اسهل من انه يخطئ
الهدف ويروح باتجاه خاطئ الامر الثاني انه
لازم يكون في انسان لديه خبره في الحياه
يدلك على الطريق الصحيح
الامر الثالث اللي حبيت اذكره من قصه
حياتي هاي
انه انا درست ست سنوات في فرنسا بعرف
الحياه فيها وبعرف الحياه في سوريا وبعرف
المعاناه اليوم بعد 12 سنه من الحرب
القاسيه جدا والحصار الاقتصادي
اللي خلف حقيقه معاناه هائله وصراع لدى
الشباب المتعلمين والكفاءات العلميه
خلاهم يسعوا باتجاه السفر الهجره
اللي انا كنت اسعاره حقيقه لكن الامر
مختلف
اليوم ما في شك بانه هذا الوضع اللي نحن
عايشينه وعم نعاني منه كشهادات علميه
وخريجين
باختصاصات مختلفه عم نعاني وهذه المعاناه
عامه لكن عم بتخلي الشباب ينزحوا
بالتفكيرهم باتجاه الهجره بشكل عام
انا واحد من الناس خلال 12 سنه الماضيه
والحرب مريت
بامتحان نفسي انا بطبيعه عملي بسافر
زيارات علميه الى مخابر في اوروبا او حضور
مؤتمرات علميه خلال الحرب بصراحه
راودتني نفسي
من الزملاء من الرفاق كثير من زملائي
تركوا البلد وراحوا
لكن الحقيقه في كل مره كنت فاضل بين
الايجابيات والسلبيات قد احسب حسابات
بالنسبه الي مستند الى افكار كانت دائما
ترجح كفه البقاء
ابقى في سوريا
راح ازر اذكر ثلاث من هذه الافكار اللي
انا خلتني ابقى في سوريا واللي لعلها
بتفيد الناس والشباب والكفاءات العلميه
اللي بدهم يسافروا او اللي بدهم يبقوا
البلد لكن قبل ما اذكر هالثلاث افكار
اسمحوا لي اني احكي بعض الكلمات عن الهجره
الهجره بشكل عام انه الانسان ينتقل من
مكان الى مكان اخر بحثا عن حياه وبيئه
افضل وهذا الامر مشروع بالمطلق
السعي نحو الافضل هو امر مشروع وهو امر
طبيعي
طبيعي من ان الهجره موجوده في الطبيعه من
منا لا يعلم هجره طائر السنونو طائر
السنون ياتي الى بلدنا سوريا في كل عام
حتى ان اول طائر يصل هو من يبلغ الفلاحين
في قرانا انه قد حل الربيع من دون النظر
الى الروزنامه
طائر السنون يجتاز مسافات طويله جدا وعدد
من البلدان دون حاجز مصطنع ولا يقف طائر
الدوري المستوطن في بلدنا ليقول للسنون
فرجيني جواز السفرك وين الفيزا شو جاي
تساوي
طائر السنون
طبعا حتى الدوري لا يطلب من السنون انه
مفهوم الموجود حاليا في الدول المتقدمه
يعني الاندماج يعني عليك يا طائر السنون
ان تهرب بطريقتي ان تبني اعشاشك بطريقه كل
هذه الامور غير موجوده من في الطبيعه في
الهجره الطبيعيه الاهم في الهجره الطبيعيه
ان طائر السنون بحلول الخريف
يعود من حيث جاء اذا الهجره الطبيعيه
السليمه هي الهجره التي تنتهي دائما
بالعوده الى الوطن مثال اخر من الطبيعه
ايضا
سمك السلمون من منا لم يسمع عن هجره سمك
السلمون الذي يجتاز مسافات طويله جدا من
البحار الى اعالي الانهار ليضع بيوضه
يتجاوز الشلالات وخطر الدبب الموجوده في
مساره يضع البيوت ثم تعود اسماك السلمون
في الهجره طبيعيه الى موطنها الاصلي
بالمناسبه
الدببه لو تكلمت
وسالناها هل انتم ضد هجره سمك السلمون
حكما الدببه ستقول بالعكس نود ان تكون
اسماك السلم على مدار العام اذا الهجره
الطبيعيه لا يوجد فيها حاجز مصطنعي يهدد
الحياه
وتنتهي دائما بالعوده فما بالكم بهجره
العقول بهجره الكفاءات بهجره حمله
الشهادات الذين اذا هاجروا دون ان يعودوا
يدمر اوطانهم وليس بالضروره انهم سينجحوا
بالعوده الى النقاط الثلاثي التي انا
ارتكزت عليها والتي انصحت بها كل من يود
ان يسافر او يود ان يبقى اذا هناك قيم في
الحياه يجب ان يبحث عيناها عليها الانسان
اينما حل اول قيمه حقيقه
البحث عن الاحترام
الاحترام ان لم يكن الانسان محترما في
حياته لا معنى للحياه
اذا سافر احدكم الى بلد
واعتبر
مواطن من الدرجه الثانيه او الثالث وقل له
انه اولادك ممكن يكونوا مواطنين حقيقه بس
حياتك انت خسرتها
انا ساذكر لكم قصه من تجربه الشخصيه في
فرنسا لما بدات تروح للدكتوراه دخلت في
مخبر في جامعه بيرو وماري كوري كنت طالب
من بين عده طلاب فرنسيين واجانب انا كنت
الاجنبي الذي
سيعود الى بلد الحقيقه
انه عاملني الفرنسيون بطريقه
خياليه لم اكن اتوقع طبعا كانوا يعرفوا
انا بدي ارجع لبلدي
لم اكن اشعر بالتميز على الاطلاق عن
الفرنسيه
وكنت دائما اشعر اني
متميز عن الطلاب الذين سيبقون في فرنسا
فتحوا لي كل الابواب اعطوني كل ما اريد
علموني حتى انهم
اعتبروني حلقه وصل انسانيه مع بلد يحتاج
الى واحد مثلي يعني كنت نقطه التقاء
ثقافيه حضاريه انسانيه لذلك هذه القيمه
اللي انا حسيت فيها بنصح فيها كل انسان
ولا تتحقق الا اذا كان بده يرجع لبلد
اذا
بالهجره الطبيعيه الهجره الايجابيه
بالهجره التي فيها هجره السنون فيها عوده
الى البلد تكتسب الاحترام حتى اكثر الناس
في الدول الاوروبيه تشددا ضد الاجانب
عندما يعلمون انك قادم لكي تتعلم وتعود
الى بلدك لتبني بلدك سيساعدوك بدلا من ان
يقفوا في طريقك النقطه او الفكره الثاني
هي فكره قيمه العمل
في البشريه هناك ميزان ميزان ما بين العمل
من جهه
والحاجه او الاجر من جهه ثانيه هذا في
البشريه هناك توازن انت تعمل لقاء اجر
لقاء احتياجات عندما تنتقل من مكان الى
مكان تحصل على احتياجاتك لقاء العمل لكن
في الانسانيه
هذا الميزان يرجح لصالح يرجح لصالح العمل
لان للعمل قيمه للعمل اثر خصوصا في قصه
مثل قصتي ساضرب ايضا مثال واطبقه عليه انا
كدكتور في الفيزياء لو اني بقيت في فرنسا
وكنت اتحدث الان من فرنسا مثلا الحقيقه
انا على ثقه بانه هناك
عشرات بل مئات من هم باختصاصي في فرنسا
يعني وجودي او عدم وجودي في فرنسا سيان
اما وجودي في سوريا اليوم فانا اجزم انه
ما في على عدد الاصابع منهم باختصاصي اذا
قيمه عملي قيمه عملي اكبر هذا الميزان
سيختل لصالح الانسانيه عندما اكون في بلدي
الانسان في نهايه مساره في الحياه
يطرح عده اسئله
من بين الاسئله التي يطرحها الانسان اين
ساموت بجوار من ساموت اين ساكون من بجواري
والسؤال الاهم انا ماذا فعلت في حياتي
ماذا قدمت كل الاحتياجات في الميزان الان
معنى لها القيمه هي في العمل لذلك اقول
عندما تعود الى بلدانكم الى المواطن التي
تحتاجكم الى تحتاج اختصاصاتكم فانكم
تضيفون قيمه لن تقدروها الا في نهايه
الحياه
الامر الثالث والاهم
المعاناه
جميعنا نعاني جميعنا مرينا في المعامله
المعاناه امر سلبي بالمطلق لا يمكن لاحد
ان يقول ان المعاناه امر ايجابيه لكن
الايجابيين هم من يحولون المعاناه الى
فرصه والى نجاح انا لولا المعاناه ما
تفوقت في الجامعه
سنين الاولى الاولى والثانيه من فرنسا
كلها معاناه دراسه بطريقه هائله جدا كلها
معاناه
انا اذا سالتوني الان عن اجمل فتره في
حياتي بالحقيقه اقول ست سنوات اللي قضيتها
في فرنسا لكن لو ان اليوم اتكلم من فرنسا
وسئلت نفس السؤال ما كنت ساجيب بانه ست
سنوات الاولى من حياتي في فرنسا هي اجمل
ايام حياتي على الاطلاق اجمل سنين حياتي
كانت ستكون لو اني في فرنسا
دراسه الجامعيه التي عانيت فيها وتفوقت
فيها وانجزت فيها دائما الانسان يكتشف
الجمال
ومعاني الحياه في منعطفات الحياه عندما
يغير مساره بالاتجاهات الايجابيه
انصح الشباب والمتعلمين والكفاءات العلميه
دائما
بالاخذ بعين الاعتبار
الاحترام البحث عن الاحترام وتحويل قيمه
العمل الى قيمه انسانيه وتحويل المعاناه
الى فرصه في الحياه
من لا يستطيع السفر
الحقيقه
لن يجد امامه الا ان يعمل في المكان الذي
هو فيه الحقيقه ان من يعمل في المكان من
يصنع المكان من يبدع في مكانه اهم بكثير
ممن ينتقل الى مكان اخر
[موسيقى]
مهيا كل شيء فيه
لا يساهم في انشاؤه ساضرب مثال نحن بين
البشر انتم تستمعون عن حرائق الغابات
تدمير الارض التلوث قد نضطر في يوم من
الايام للهجره خارج الكره الارضيه نحن
البشر
في ذلك اليوم سنكون مضطرين لبناء مستوطنات
معلقه في الفضاء او على سطح احد الكواكب
غير القابله للحياه
اذا نحن كبشر سنكون مضطرين لبناء الوطن
لماذا لا نبنيه الان الشخص الذي لا يقف في
وطنه ويبنيه ويسعى فقط براءه احتياجاته
هذا انسان مستهلك ليس انسان فاعل في
الحياه
لذلك
فرصه من يبقى في الوطن وهذا السبب الذي
جعلني ابقى في بلدي لابحث عن القيمه في
نهايه الحياه ولاصنع شيء
لعلكم تعلمون ان الحمام هو رمز المحبه
والسلام
ومن انواع الحمام هناك الحمام الزاجل
الحمام الزاجل في اي اتجاه ذهب ولاي مسافه
ابتعد دائما يعود الى موطنه
انصح الشباب والمتعلمين وعملت الشهادات ان
يكونوا كالحمام الزاجل اذا سافروا ان
ياخذوا معهم المحبه والسلام والبحث عن
العلم ولكن ان يعودوا
كملحمام الزاجل
ليحملوا رساله رساله العلم والمعرفه
والتطور لبناء بلدهم لبناء الوطن وببناء
الوطن انت تبني الانساني شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]